the suicide rate in this in this country
is on the rise as a matter of fact the
suicide rate is higher than the homicide
rate in this country if you can believe
that this month's deaths of designer
Kate Spade and Chef Anthony Bourdain
gave a new urgency to Suicide Prevention
we spoke with five people to provide
their Insight each is a suicide attempt
Survivor Chris Goldsmith is a former
soldier who served in Iraq and now
advocates for veterans Lisa yob is a
mother of four who helps run her
family's Child Focus Foundation Desiree
stage is a photographer whose website
lived through this is dedicated to
suicide attempt survivors mental health
Advocate that's kelechi ubosa is a rape
Survivor and a journalist turned poet
and Greg Loomis is a father of two who
promotes mental well-being through yoga
he says they shared important advice
with us and a message of Hope
I'm very touched that you would share
your story you should know that we're
all here
because we do want to learn how to be
better and do better but what is it that
we don't understand people
with mental illness
are not monsters I live with bipolar
illness I have for most of my life I've
lost my
my birth mom to sue us up
my grandmother to suicide
and
I'm a three-time attempt to Survivor
suicide's not a disease
suicide is not a disease suicide is an
event
like anything else if you've tried three
times how do people close to you know
he's okay now they don't they don't they
don't my own family doesn't trust me
to this day what so many people are
wrestling with when people make the
decision to take their own lives is how
could they do that to their children how
could they leave their children behind
is that the wrong question for us to ask
absolutely you are not you are not in
any way thinking that way what are you
thinking in my mind and in my case I was
seeing how my life had spun out of
control and I didn't know how to reach
out and so when I saw that I just was
hitting bottom
and I thought of the burden I was going
to become to my kids that's when it was
rational to me that they would be much
better off without me so in your mind
you weren't leaving them you were
actually thinking you were a burden to
them and that they would be better they
would be in a better situation it's okay
to not be okay this is normal it's okay
to not be okay it's okay to not be okay
I had spent a year in Iraq from ages 18
to 19. my job involved photographing of
mass Graves and it haunted me in ways
that I couldn't understand and I didn't
have the vocabulary to describe I had
lost purpose in my life I had lost
control of everything
attempting suicide was an expression of
control over my own destiny we all go
through something that's very jarring to
us what's the difference between someone
who just Powers through and someone else
that just says I can't take it anymore
is there an answer to that Desiree I
think we all have a different capacity
for pain and our ability to withstand it
what could be
life-threatening to me in terms of
suicide could be your Tuesday definitely
specific to people why we go through it
how we got here I have to say it's very
different for each person every person
I'm learning from the experts in your
field that it's incorrect to say they
committed suicide to say that you
committed suicide is similar to you
committed rape or you committed and
murdered or you committed adultery it's
a sin to commit something suicide is a
symptom it's not a sin you know before I
came I was talking to experts and they
said you should not ask how they
attempted suicide and I said why is that
an impolite or inappropriate question
it's been proven to be unsafe it
triggers people I read a story about how
How Deeply affected Kate Spade was by
Robin Williams suicide death yeah and we
we know that Robin Williams death was
covered we knew exactly how he did it
where he did it what he did it with and
Kate Spade did it the same way and then
we described it again and then we had
Anthony Bourdain well I wrote why make
that Gore Factor the important part what
about the pain sometimes we're thinking
well I don't want to talk about it
because if I ask her how she's doing or
ask him how he's doing that'll just make
him feel really bad
and then I could trigger something
should we ask you should we go and talk
to you about it what should we do
there's a myth out there that if you ask
someone if they're suicidal that the it
will trigger a thought of suicide that's
not true if the thought wasn't there
you're not going to make it there you're
not planning it if it wasn't you're not
planning it there and I think what
people tend to do because they're afraid
is say you're not thinking about doing
something stupid are you yeah and then I
now know that you think that's stupid so
I'm not going to tell you that I might
not tell you the truth so it's really
actually really like hey you seem really
down have you had thoughts of harm are
you okay do you want to go for a walk
did all of you hide how you were feeling
I absolutely did a fantastic job of
always being on point yeah
um I was at the OCD mom the OCD CEO but
see this is what scares me Lisa if we
don't know you're in trouble how are
your friends and your family supposed to
help you if you all hide all of this
from us because we need to know that
it's safe to tell you if it's not safe
to tell you we're going to hide it and I
want to say we have to hide I'm making a
choice to now step out even though I've
lost my job for disclosing that I had a
mental health issue what happened I took
on a job at a pediatric office and I was
just doing some like clerk work and the
person who attacked me reached out to me
and that triggered me I started having
thoughts of suicide and I told my boss I
said hey I'm having thoughts of suicide
and she says oh my God kalechi why don't
you go home why don't you take care of
yourself do you know that I went to work
the next day and I heard her telling the
doctor we have to fire collections she's
crazy you heard her say you never say
that I had openly shared that and then I
lost my jobs there's a real risk to
sharing I heard guys about that
everybody or many people have a safe
plan I have a safe plan I would be
curious to hear what is your safe plan
um my resources taught me was to have
like a core group of six people and they
received a safety plan and that
basically says if I'm not leaving my
house if I'm not returning your phone
calls if you your texts go unanswered
for you know days at a time if you see
me overly happy or appearing to be
overly happy
those are symptoms that you need to
reach out and ask me how I am my plan is
less formal you know I the the person
who attempted suicide at 23 and the
person I am now at 35 they're completely
different human beings I have a
beautiful perfect life now of an amazing
wife I have a new son and so when things
get hard for me and they do and I'm not
having suicidal thoughts but I'm
depressed I just tell everybody I'm like
hey it's not awesome today Greg do you
have a safe plan the only plan I have is
when I wake up every morning I find a
reason
to live that day what was your reason
today to live uh to be to do this
somebody will see this
and they'll say
if he can do what I can do it and
they'll go get help
oh Gail yeah I mean I have to tell you I
didn't know any of them of course but I
was so touched by every single one of
them eight sharing their stories so
candidly we really should figure out a
way to put it all online because it is
so good and so important what they had
to say and they said you're not giving
anybody ideas and if you suspect
something you really do just have to ask
him Chris said to me if you're good with
your words use your words if you're a
hugger go and hug the worst thing you
can do is to say nothing right because
you think if I don't if I don't call
attention it'll go away it won't well I
know we've talked about it and you're
wanting to find more understandings
about this and I think that's really I
learned more from listening to them that
I think I have in reading everything
I've read just about the idea of how you
know when someone is safe how you know
when someone is in trouble I mean
incredibly useful information yeah and
that expression making it safe to tell
you yes creating a space in your
relationships with people you think are
in trouble or might not be where it's
safe for them to tell you that was an
amazing yeah because you would think of
the famous people that we know you think
well surely they had friends and they
had family but if you don't feel safe
they said they are not going to say
anything to you that was very very
eye-opening to me really I liked all
those guys so much I did too liked them
all very much and strong people and I'm
grateful too guys that they shared their
story that they felt comfortable enough
and safe enough to sit out in that park
and talk to us so so openly uh Bravo to
Andy merlis who edited that piece
because that would get a lot to work
with if you or someone you know is in
crisis contact the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline they said this is
important too because I said who's going
to call a lifetime they said you'd be
surprised how many people call at
1-800-273-8255 you can also find more
information on our website at
cbsthismorning.com